Hello and welcome to a special episode of Speaking of Psychology, a podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. This special episode features a report by APA's Kim Mills, who attended the first ever International Summit on Psychology's contributions to global health in Lisbon, Portugal in November. The summit, sponsored by APA and the Association of Portuguese Psychologists, brought together leaders of psychological associations from more than 40 nations on five continents to explore ways of applying psychological science to the global problem of climate change.
您好，欢迎收听美国心理学会播客《心理学谈话》的特别节目，本节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。本期特别节目由美国心理学会的基姆·米尔斯报道，她参加了去年11月在葡萄牙里斯本举行的首届“心理学对全球健康的贡献国际峰会”。此次峰会由美国心理学会和葡萄牙心理学家协会共同主办，汇集了来自五大洲40多个国家的心理学协会领导人，共同探讨如何将心理科学应用于应对气候变化这一全球性问题。
The summit kicked off with several psychologists describing climate change's impact in their countries. Jean Young-Che, Secretary of External Affairs for the Korean Psychological Association, described how microdust is engulfing the country and noted evidence suggesting a connection between dementia and exposure to the fine particles. Ava Thompson, past president of the Bahamas Psychological Association, noted the increasing frequency and power of hurricanes in the Caribbean. And Brian Dixon, Director of Scientific Issues for the New Zealand Psychological Society, described how flooding is devastating his city and surrounding areas.
峰会伊始，多位心理学家描述了气候变化对各自国家的影响。韩国心理学会对外事务秘书让·杨-切描述了微尘如何笼罩该国，并指出有证据表明痴呆症与接触这些细颗粒物之间存在联系。巴哈马心理学会前主席艾娃·汤普森提到了加勒比地区飓风频率和强度的增加。新西兰心理学会科学事务主任布莱恩·迪克森则描述了洪水如何摧毁了他的城市及周边地区。
Well, we're a coastal nation, and all of our borders are threatened by, climate change with increasing sea levels, increasing storm events. But we also have problems with our glaciers, lake snowfall, and those are major tourist attractions for us. And our food production areas which are subject to drought and flooding more frequently now than they have been in the past. Our territorial realm covers a lot of the Pacific, which means that a large number of climate change migrants and refugees
我们是一个沿海国家，所有的边界都受到气候变化、海平面上升和风暴事件增加的威胁。但我们还面临冰川和湖泊降雪的问题，这些对我们来说是主要的旅游景点。我们的粮食产区现在比过去更容易受到干旱和洪水的影响。我们的领土范围覆盖了太平洋的大部分地区，这意味着大量的气候变化移民和难民
are likely to come to our country, which would place a huge stress on our health systems, our mental health systems, and just our community resources. The attendees issued a proclamation committing each organization to work together on the United Nations Sustainable Development Goal Number 13, which calls for taking action to combat climate climate change and its impacts. They also adopted a resolution committing them to, among other things, helping people prepare for and adapt to climate change, even as psychologists work to change
很可能会来到我国，这将给我们的卫生系统、心理健康系统以及社区资源带来巨大压力。与会者发表了一项宣言，承诺各组织共同致力于联合国可持续发展目标第13项，即采取行动应对气候变化及其影响。他们还通过了一项决议，承诺在其他事项中，帮助人们为气候变化做好准备并适应气候变化，即使心理学家们也在努力改变
the behaviors that have caused it. The president of Portugal, Marcelo Rebello de Sousa, addressed the summit telling attendees they had chosen the right subject to tackle first because of the global nature of climate change. We must have a global response to it. then there's not a single country, even a superpower, that can alone address this issue. Many of the attendees agreed with the president's assessment. Dr. Christine Roland Levy, president of the International Association of Applied Psychology, was one. We really have to be global and take into account the differences in terms of cultures, in terms of habits, in terms of global warming as a whole.
导致气候变化的行为。葡萄牙总统马塞洛·雷贝洛·德索萨在峰会上致辞，告诉与会者，由于气候变化的全球性，他们选择了最先解决的正确课题。我们必须对此做出全球性的反应。没有一个国家，即使是超级大国，能够单独解决这个问题。许多与会者同意总统的评估。国际应用心理学协会主席克里斯汀·罗兰·列维博士就是其中之一。我们确实必须全球化，并考虑到文化、习惯以及全球变暖整体方面的差异。
problems are not always the same. Focus should be different according to countries, but we should, and we need to have the same goal, protect the planet, make it a better world for the future, make it a better world for the future generations. So that's the main point. APA CEO, Dr. Arthur Evans Jr., called the meeting a landmark for psychology around the world.
问题并不总是相同的。重点应根据国家的不同而有所区别，但我们应该，也需要有同一个目标，即保护地球，为未来创造一个更美好的世界，为子孙后代创造一个更美好的世界。这就是重点所在。美国心理学会首席执行官阿瑟·埃文斯博士称这次会议是全球心理学的一个里程碑。
He and Francisco Miranda Rodriguez, president of the Association of Portuguese Psychologists, agreed to continue to continue to provide administrative support to the international associations after they return home and begin to implement some of the tactics agreed upon. These will include a systematic review of existing research, plus new cross-cultural research, seeking increased funding from government and philanthropic sources
他和葡萄牙心理学家协会主席弗朗西斯科·米兰达·罗德里格斯一致同意，在他们回国并开始实施商定的一些策略后，继续为国际协会提供行政支持。这些策略将包括对现有研究进行系统综述，开展新的跨文化研究，并寻求政府和慈善机构增加资金支持
and conducting interdisciplinary workshops and conferences. Other ideas that emerged included holding sessions on climate change at each association's annual conference, devoting special issues of their journals to the time. topic, sponsoring publicity campaigns and training psychologists about how to change behavior and help people cope with climate change and climate disasters. I think that people came with some energy and excitement about the topic, but I think people are leaving with a commitment to really work on this issue going forward.
以及举办跨学科研讨会和会议。其他涌现出的想法包括：在每个协会的年度会议上举行关于气候变化的会议，在期刊上开辟专题讨论该主题，赞助宣传活动，并培训心理学家如何改变行为，帮助人们应对气候变化和气候灾难。我认为人们带着对这个话题的精力和兴奋而来，但我认为人们离开时带着致力于在未来真正解决这个问题的承诺。
And not only that, I think we educated each other, both having experts that came to the room and to the room to talk with us, but also people who had lived experience. psychologists who were in countries that were affected by climate change, and they had an opportunity to talk about the psychological impact and toll in the world that they saw psychology playing. So I think that combination was really powerful. Thank you, Kim Mills, for that interesting report from the summit in Lisbon. I hope we'll have more to say about psychology and climate change in the coming months. For more information about the summit and to view a video of portions of the meeting, go to our website, speaking
不仅如此，我认为我们互相教育，既有专家来到现场与我们交谈，也有拥有生活经验的人。那些身处受气候变化影响国家的心理学家们，他们有机会谈论心理影响以及他们所看到的心理学在世界上发挥的作用。所以我认为这种结合非常强大。感谢基姆·米尔斯从里斯本峰会发回的有趣报道。我希望在接下来的几个月里，我们能就心理学和气候变化进行更多的讨论。有关峰会的更多信息以及观看会议部分视频，请访问我们的网站，speaking
of psychology. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to speakingof psychology.org. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. Thanks for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
of psychology。您可以在Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。您也可以访问speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。感谢收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。